[Music]
you
it's interesting that she mentioned that
I've been here since 2007 as a lecturer
I can always tell when a new school year
begins because my bio now says for more
than 25 years he has been in hire for
more than it used to be a small number
and the the challenge about teaching at
a college or university is that every
year freshmen are 18 and you're one more
year further away from that I I am
delighted for the conversation we were
about to have and I am humbled as I know
more about the jedikiah award in fact
they were gonna take it away
I said no let it let it sit out here for
my talk and and it sometimes is called
the Golden Apple the Silver Apple so I
want to get apples to put in my silver
bowl but I didn't have time to do that
on the break that we had when I think of
2007 and when I came to the GSB it was
it was a really remarkable thing that
the GSB did to create a slot for a
faculty member in communication I had
been at the NYU Stern School of Business
where I earned my MBA shortly after
finishing my MBA I was appointed to the
faculty not a pathway very many MBA
students aspire to but it was the one
that I wanted and I taught at Stern for
from 2002 when I graduated until 2007
when Stanford whisked me away but
Stanford hadn't had a slot on the
faculty for a communications professor
since Mary Munter left in 1983 and so
there had been a 24 year period with no
credit bearing classes in communication
at the GSB until in Rio in redesigning
the curriculum for the fall of 2007 they
created the critical
thinking course and that had a very
heavy writing component and so they
created a communication slot to create
to support that course and create a team
of coaches but it was really evident to
me somewhere in my second week on the
job I was in the faculty room and I was
trying to operate the copier and figure
out what the code was to put in and and
Jeff Pfeffer we most all of us know Jeff
Pfeffer in his inimitable fashion came
into the copier room and he's like who
are you I don't know you and it's one JD
Schrom I just joined the faculty goes oh
you're Mary munchers replacement 24
years I don't know that we would really
call that a replacement but it was a
great thing both for me personally and
professionally that that Stanford made
the choice to open that slot and that I
could step into that I often say that I
have the privilege of teaching at a
school that I'm not sure I could get
into and there's a little bit of
self-deprecation in that but there also
is it is an awesome privilege to get to
work with students and alumni from the
GSB and every new quarter I am reminded
of that and what I hope to share with
you in the next hour that we have
together is is what some of that awesome
privilege feels like and looks like and
I'm also going to bring into the
conversation
some of my students and and former
students so that you can have a little
bit of the experience that I get to have
every day and it's fascinating to me
that not only do I get to be in the
classroom but I get to interact with
alumni on my most recent alumni event
was in the living room of Wynn Chesson
in New York City he had a gathering of
LGBTQ alumni in New York City that I got
to be be the guest for just a few months
ago and my next alumni event is the last
Tuesday in October I'm going to be in
Singapore my husband and I are doing
some consulting and the night before the
consulting begins
fan and some of the Singapore alumni
have put together an event and so those
are rich opportunities for me and now I
get to have it with hundreds of you all
at one time so let's get rolling shall
we I I titled this talk communicate with
mastery speak with conviction and write
for impact and and that really is the
heart of what I have taught here at the
GSB since 2007
and I can't give you all of that in an
hour but I can give you a taste of it as
well as some homework as well as some
resources that you can use to build your
own mastery as a leader who communicates
I will on near the end take time for
questions and so if you've got questions
that bubble up inside I'll indicate
where is a great time to ask that and I
just ask that you wait for the mics to
come around so that for the livestream
audience hello everybody out on
livestream I is at the DMV watching us
right now so hey Toby good to see you
get your car registered you're illegal
right now but and for the recording we
want to be sure that we capture that and
with that here's the agenda here's what
I'd like to look at in preparing for
this honor and this talk I looked at
what has made not me but what has made
us successful at the GSB in the last 12
years around teaching communication why
had we gone through such a period of
time where we didn't offer it in the
curriculum and now where it is one of
the most sought-after electives probably
behind touchy-feely and design for
extreme affordability we are we are up
there in terms of waiting lists and
being sought out so what are the seven
secrets to Stanford's success since oh
seven I love alliteration and then I
will move out of the seven secrets and
give you some four very practical steps
that you can take based on the
information that I'm sharing with you
and then close with some gifts some
resources that I'd like to guide you to
as we look at this I teach this formula
in my classes the finance professors are
not amazed at the new
of my of my of my formulas here but I
really believe that the communication is
leadership and by the transitive
property leadership is communication the
the senior leaders that I work with at
the University and outside the
University when they have a
communication issue it usually is a
leadership issue and when they have a
leadership issue it usually is a
communication issue the two are very
closely tied to each other and yet
communication is a distinct discipline
how do I write how do I speak how do I
stand in front of a group of people and
have presence how do I send an email to
an individual or have a phone call with
one person and accomplish what I want to
accomplish in that and so I see that the
two are very intertwined with each other
they have one more formula that I'll
give you before we get out of the
finance world and into the communication
world and and that is I want to remind
you what an asymptote is now an
asymptote is a curve that gets closer
and closer and closer and closer to the
line but never crosses the line if this
were to go up in infinity all the way to
forever that blue line would never cross
that black line but it would keep
getting closer and closer and closer to
it Dan pink and his awesome book drive
talks about mastery as getting better
and better at something that matters
better and better at something that
matters for me that's communication for
other people that that might be golf or
that might be cooking or that might be
parenting but it's something that that
you never are going to get to perfection
you can every speech you give could
always be just a little bit better my
MBA students and MSX students this
morning we sat in for 20 minutes
critiqued Oprah Winfrey and her Golden
Globes acceptance speech which i think
is a phenomenal speech and even Oprah
could have done better and my MBA and
MSX students knew and they could figure
out where it where it was little
inauthentic or where it was just a
little bit rough and wasn't as smooth so
all of us any
thing we write anything we speak can
always incrementally make that better
and we just know that we do that without
ever hitting perfection it's not
possible to do the perfect speech
although I'm going to do the best I can
it won't be perfect there's already
things that I could have improved so
then let's look at the 7 secrets of
Stanford's success since o 7 first
invite great people to collaborate
invite great people to collaborate I was
tasked with in the fall of o7 hiring at
first a team of writing coaches who
would work with the mba students in the
cat course that that was being launched
because there was so much writing
involved in the course the faculty
wanted to be sure that the students were
supported and were writing effectively
and so we first put a team of writing
coaches together and then in the next
year we began to add other lecturers to
the faculty and other coaches to the
coaching body and what we do we still go
back one here we still have a very rich
tradition of communication coaching
since o7 every incoming mba and MSX
student is assigned a professional
communication coach to work with them
for their entire first quarter no other
business school has replicated this
since we launched this in 2007 and they
work with them on how to write how to
speak and how to participate in class oh
is phenomenal I know at times the MSX
students are like given second class or
our back row sort of things we're so
awesome our communication coach worked
with the MSX students on class
participation this summer that coach
happens to be my co-instructor and we
walked in on the first day of class and
I started class discussion all of the
participation came from the MSX students
I was like can I hear from an MBA
student can just one of you raised your
hand and enter the conversation and it
was it was both the culture of MBA two's
wanting to lay back a little bit they
were just off of their summer we'll call
it internships but but it was very
evident that the MSX students had been
primed for participation in a way that
the MBA students had not yet and so this
year
we actually have a team of seven coaches
very diverse group of professionals who
do communication coaching for a living
and they take a cut in pay and I hit in
their practice to spend the fall quarter
with our students working with him
intensely but we knew that it wasn't
just being able to coach students
effectively we also needed to be able to
have credit bearing courses that the
students would engage rigorously with
faculty members around what we were
doing so in the fall of oh seven I was
his sole practitioner there I am I
actually looks at her in 2007 I tried to
find my old bio pictures but they
weren't they weren't easily available on
Google at midnight last night when I was
finishing my slides but since the fall
of 2000 so in the spring of 2007 before
I was hired there was exactly zero
communication courses offered at the GSB
this fall there are over 22 sections of
communication taught by a variety of
lecturers we added Matt Abraham's who
was honored with this award last year
I'll talk about his book in a moment
David Demarest former communication
director in the first President Bush's
White House Glen crimen who is a
managing former managing editor at the
New York Times
Raymond Nasir who is the communication
coach to Eric Schmidt and has been a
part of teaching the course Eric teaches
Alyson Kluger a former television
producer Burt Alper who is an
entrepreneur with a branding background
Kirsten Hansen who works here in the
valley with a number of startup
companies and established companies and
Stephanie's sole heir at GSB grad so we
have now nine of us teaching
communication courses and co-teaching
communication courses and we're all
lecturers but we're offering a lot of
opportunities for students in the
classroom to get better at writing
speaking and participating and our
tenured colleagues have followed suit
and I counted 20 different sections of
classes offered by tenured faculty that
relate to communication including Debbie
Grund Feld's acting with power christian
wheelers the improvisational manager
and a number of other classes that are
communication related so I think we've
really upped our game and we were
talking in the deans presentation
earlier about how do you measure success
I think our success is measured by our
alumni who are out there in the field
more effective at writing speaking and
and leading because they're good
communicators these are just some of the
titles of communication courses that we
now offer here at the GSB I'm always a
little hesitant when I talk with a group
of alumni because you look at that list
you know we don't have that one I was
here but we recognized that you you are
able to experience this as you come back
to campus so hopefully we'll give you a
taste of this so the first thing is in
fact invited great people to collaborate
with you the second is to use effective
frameworks and I'm gonna give you now
the first frameworks of this afternoon's
class it is
we can't just teach skills like there is
a public speaking class at the
engineering school it has been there for
decades maybe some of you even took it
it's an awesome skills based class in
public speaking but we're teaching
leadership communications and we need to
have research frameworks as well as the
practical application so the first
framework that I begin almost every
class and anything that I do is the aim
framework developed by Lynne Russell
when she was at the Columbia Business
School and Mary Munter after she left
here and went to the Tuck Business
School at Dartmouth any time you are
going to write or speak to a group of
people slow down and ask yourself what's
my aim who is my audience what do I know
about them what are their expectations
what is their culture do whatever you
can to understand your audience before
you write or speak and then to clarify
what your intent is what's your purpose
your objective your goal the question I
like to ask my students is as a result
of this conversation you want the
audience to think or say or do what I
want the audience to do what if you
can't answer that you're not clear on
your intent you shouldn't be writing or
speaking don't waste our time with that
don't hold that meeting unless you know
what your intent is a few years ago I
was working with the CEO of Stanford's
hospital we were prepping a town-hall
meeting that he was going to deliver to
his to his staff and I stopped him about
halfway through I'm like Dan what's your
intent I want to impress them
I said well great it's all about you
what do you want the audience to think
sir do I want them to be impressed
like great that's still all about you as
a result of the Town Hall what do you
want them to do differently because I
want them to treat patients with dignity
yeah
now we're in the world of intent and if
you as a leader can't specify what you
want people to do at the bottom of the
email or at the end of the phone message
or at the end of the meeting don't
deliver that communication until you are
clear about it I had the chance this
year to speak at a conference that one
of our alumni invited me to the
Qualtrics summit in Salt Lake City and
Oprah Winfrey Barack Obama and me okay
they were headliners and I was like in a
breakout room but that that's the way I
remember the story is sandwiched in
between Oprah and Barack but I got to
hear Oprah's talk at Qualtrics and she
talked about intent in a way that I
haven't heard other people describe it
she told the story of in early in her
career she was doing a show and the show
was about infidelity she had a man who
had been unfaithful to his wife he was
going to be on the show
his wife was gonna be on the show and
his girlfriend was gonna be on the show
and the girlfriend had decided this was
the best time to tell the wife that she
was expecting I'm like this is Oprah's
this Jerry Springer like what show are
we describing here and Oprah said no
woman regardless of her relationship to
infidelity no woman needs to learn that
on national television and not on my
show
what is our intent in putting this on
the air and she said at that moment not
only could they not define the intent of
that show she said for the rest of her
career nothing went on the air that she
and her
production team didn't agree what is our
intention with the audience that if we
don't have that we don't do this show
and and it worked out well for her and
it will work out well well for us as
leaders if we clarify that intent first
once you know a and I you can get to em
you can then decide how I'm gonna
structure the message what language I'm
gonna use I'm gonna tell a story am I
gonna use slides we use a video clip
then you can get to what the message is
but slow yourself down and define who's
the audience what's the intent the
biggest mistake leaders make today is
they jump immediately to the message
they want to share without considering
who needs to hear it and what action
should they take because of that so this
framework the aim framework so wished
I'd have developed it but I use it with
with great citation and honor to Mary
Munter and Lynne Russell but it's one of
the simplest ways to think about
communication strategy when we not only
use great frameworks we do also steel
good frameworks that that is in academia
that's that's called using effective
citations there is a framework that
Daniel dear Meyer at the I believe now
is the provost at University of Chicago
in his book reputation rules he that we
use in our reputation management class
he has a framework for teaching leaders
how to handle crisis communication his
framework looks something like this that
when a company is going through a crisis
there are four things that we expect of
that leader we want that leader to be to
display empathy transparency expertise
and commitment and and in his book
chapter after chapter he uses this trust
radar and the greater footprint that the
radar has the greater trust that that
company embodies now I also love I get
to talk about this story with people who
remember the stories that I'm going to
share with you but the classic example
he gives of this is the tylenol crisis
in the fall of 1982 in the fall of 1982
there were several there were 11 people
who died taking tylenol and
tylenol did not know the makers of tile
Johnson Johnson did not know where the
problem was was it at the source was it
at the manufacturing plant was it
distribution was it at the store and
while they were doing this research they
did a worldwide recall of Tylenol
I mean think for him it those of us who
were alive in the fall of 1982 like
everywhere that sells Tylenol you got to
get those bottles back off the shelf so
dear Meyer in his analysis of it rated
him this way very high on commitment
empathy and transparency the only place
he traded him low was expertise because
nobody knew how to do that big of a wide
scale withdrawal of a product from the
market so successful was tylenol in this
that within five years they were
introducing new products to the market
and the commercial on TV said from the
makers of tylenol that is a remarkable
recovery from a disaster because they
displayed those four items now he
compared that to Exxon Valdez you you
could fill in any oil crisis like this
could be BP horizon this could be you
know there's a number of oil crises we
could put up there low on commitment
expertise a commitment empathy and
transparency the only got score for is
they knew how to clean up their mess
slowly but but that I love that
framework for crisis communication and
reputation management so I stole the
framework and I just got his permission
a few weeks ago so I stole the framework
but changed the language as I started
working with LGBTQ leaders in our Summer
Institute for LGBTQ senior leaders who
are on their way to the c-suite doing a
week-long experience for them and I
started working with that group and I
took his framework and I said okay what
is it that somebody who's a leader
that's been marginalized because they're
gay or transgender or lesbian and and I
started from a blank canvas of
authenticity it is important as leaders
that we display authenticity Joel
Peterson says in the first day of class
that authenticity is such an important
skill for GSB students that if you don't
have it you
to be able to fake it and so
authenticity is the first place that we
start from I'm sorry that was really
unkind that wasn't Joel Peterson that
was Irv gross buck but anyway one one of
the two great lecturers but we start
from a canvas of authenticity and then I
looked at again the guy who loves
alliteration clarity confidence
competence and connection so as a leader
who has been marginalized in other parts
of my life or other parts of the company
other parts of the organization other
parts of society I need to step in
authentically to be clear to be
confident to be competent and to be
connected now in the full workshop that
I do on this for the senior leaders who
come to campus and the organizations
I've gone out to to deliver this at
often somebody says that's not limited
to the gays like that would work for all
of us and I acknowledge it would
actually work for all of us but there is
a unique challenge to somebody who is a
minority in an organization or the first
woman who has worked in this
organization or the first elected
official who is transgender there's a
different sort of expectation when you
are stepping into something that nobody
else has done before and so again the
greater real estate that I can have I
call this the lavender diamond the
greater real estate that I can have the
greater sense of leadership presence and
authenticity that I exhibit and I may
have to do trade offs
I may have to trade if I'm new in a job
I may not have the competence so I may
have to over index on connection and and
so we begin to look at those four and
what are the levers that move those four
forward the fourth key to our success is
cultivating a storytelling culture as
you can tell already I love telling
stories I love hearing stories I love
listening to stories I got to do
storytelling coaching with the last few
reunion classes and and I love I love
the expression that I think came from
the class of 68 that they they loved
hearing the stories at reunion after
reunion after reunion they said you know
what the
older we get the better we were I like
that I like that thought and so what do
we do to cultivate a storytelling
culture here well first of all we teach
what a great story is I love this
illustration of of the arc of a well
told story this is based on Nancy Duarte
his work who I'll talk a little bit more
about in resources and she based it on
Freytag who was a dramaturg in the late
1800s this is the five act structure of
a tragedy
hopefully the stories we're telling in
our businesses and our startups and our
lives are not tragedies but it works the
one alteration I would make to it is I
don't think we need nearly as much
exposition as we think we do I don't
think we have to give as much background
before we jump into a story and actually
teach parachuting in to the story
there's got to be some conflict some
inciting moment then a rising action
that leads to some sort of climax a
falling action and some sort of
resolution if I tell you a story about
jumping in a cab going to the airport
and catching my flight who cares
there's no story there but if I miss the
cab where I'm late for the flight or I
fight with somebody at TSA then I've got
the conflict I've got something that
started there the other thing I liked
about this this particular model you
notice that the line on resolution is
higher than the line where we begin it's
the idea that when a hero goes through a
journey when he has that he or she has
that experience that they share back out
with us in a story that they should be
transformed in some way or another
and if you think of if you look at Star
Trek and and and Luke Skywalker if you
look I'm sorry Star Wars and Luke
Skywalker if you look at Indiana Jones
if you look at Moana any of the great
heroes in in film and in literature they
all are better on the other side and the
world is better on the other side you're
familiar with the the mantra we now use
at the business school change lives
change organizations change the world I
was at MIT Sloan a few years ago and I
was working on my research for my
dissertation and they have a very still
our mantra except they use a different
verb they say improve lives I'm like
okay we just changed them their idea is
that it should be better on the other
end we just make it different on the
other end but getting to know the basic
structure of a story as I tell a story
is an important skill for our leaders to
have and so think of that as you're
telling your stories this weekend at
Reunion and let me give you an example
of a of a story in a moment here I love
this line from one of our guest speakers
who comes in James buck house he talks
about it's not just the story I tell or
the story that you hear it's a story
that you then repeat it is in that power
of having people repeat my stories
retransmit my stories that I am more
effective as a leader so I'm gonna
retransmitted ory for you now from one
of my students actually up here on the
stage two years ago Rachel Wallach
Rachel was in a program I'll tell you a
little more about in a moment called low
key notes it's kind of our version of
TED talks here at the GSB and I'm gonna
fast-forward to near the end of her talk
but I want you to look at how
beautifully she tells the story of her
experiences with health health care
providers so I was eight years old lying
on the optometrist black leather couch
after reading the last lines of 20
little letters mr. Robinson got out of
his chair and he looked over me say
Rachel you need to wear glasses but I
jumped off the chair I ran into the
store and I started trying what frame
after frame after frame I was elated and
I have never felt more glamorous than I
did back then aged eight years old
admiring my reflection with my brand-new
hot pink plastic well ten years later I
was also lying down this time it was the
hospital bed this time was different
again a doctor got up and he leaned over
me
this time he paused before saying Rachel
you're going to need to use the
wheelchair but this time there were no
choice of frames physiotherapist ordered
my wheelchair and the first time I saw
myself sitting in it I didn't recognize
myself but our glasses and wheelchairs
really so different it's not just
perceptions of how I look it's also
perceptions of Who I am
I'm gonna let you into a little secret
people often tell me I am inspirational
because I use a wheelchair that I
backpack around the world I use a
wheelchair yet I have a job I use a
wheelchair
yet I Drive a car but back when I was
just a glasses wearer no one ever told
me I inspire them but why can't we see
people who wear their wheels like people
who wear glasses why can't we view
who wear glasses this talk I use in my
teaching often this talk has forever
changed my experience of people in
wheelchairs I'm running through an
airport like on my way to catch a flight
and I see somebody in a wheelchair
I think hot pink glasses like it is
shifted my my experience of that Rachel
has gone on to found a startup called
her talk is called disrupt disability
she's gone on to found a startup called
wheel where and what wheel where is is
custom wheelchairs that are based on the
person's size and and an activity level
and desires in life and she's doing it
with with lessons that she got here at
the GSB and and it's fascinating to see
what she has done and I love that a part
of that journey was a 9 minute talk here
on this stage at Stanford stories carry
meaning and stories give us power as
leaders so the fifth strategy that's a
part of our
success is we've really embraced the Ted
movement now I'll acknowledge right at
the beginning not every talk is a TED
talk if you walk into an investment
committee meeting and you're like I'm
going to tell you a story about no
you're gonna look at some some
projections on on Excel but because Ted
is so widespread and so open source we
have really learned a lot about great
presentations and great communication
from the Ted stage we have done
simulcast of Ted here to the campus we
have had Ted speakers on their way to
Ted or their way from Ted come and
deliver their talks for our students
we've had students who've spoken at TEDx
and we've really began to see that this
is a part of our culture and part of the
conversation about great communication
we ended up creating a program here at
the GSB called low-key notes again
taking lives organization and the world
that's the low-30s an extracurricular
it's not a course that students students
take they apply to get into it and then
they spend most of the winter quarter
preparing a nine minute talk half of a
TED talk with one of the professional
communication coaches that we deploy
students report spending anywhere from
20 to 90 hours on this one nine minute
talk but it's a talk about something
that matters to them how they're gonna
step out from here and change lives
change organizations change the world
and I believe they're gonna do it it
gives me hope as I look at each year 30
more students working on their low
keynote talk Rachel was a Rachel was one
example of a low keynote talk I'm gonna
give you another one in a moment here
but not only of the students done talks
in a classroom or here on the the the C
Mac stage but they've gone on to I think
we've got six op-ed pieces in The New
York Times and The Washington Post that
are based on a low keynote talk we have
one student that B et television
approached her to do a television
special their students who've launched
startups like they've become a part of
that person's digital reputation
and it all is sourced in what they do
here so for this part I'm going to show
you I showed you the middle of Rachel's
talk I'm gonna show you the beginning
and end of another talk this is Caroline
Clark and I want you to see how she
started her talk and then we'll look
also at how she ended it quickly doctor
the doctors diagnosed me as deaf for the
next 12 years my life I've learned to
speak I spent many Sunday afternoons
with my mother on the bedroom carpet and
she teach me words they call these
sessions words and basically we will sit
there and to teach me words and I would
never forget the story that my mother
told me about the first word I learned
it was the word she hold me in her arms
and she carry me up and down the stairs
and she said to me Caroline we're going
up we go all my mom's friends and family
thought to his crazy taking on this
grand project but I want to say the word
up
I see how she open and closed her mouth
and close to the pop finally she would
take my hair and I choose please to take
my hands you place it on her boat and I
feel to the vibrations what kind of
sound to is trying to make finally at
the age of two and a half I said the
word back to her up my man when my mom
heard these words true so overjoyed she
cried tears of happiness
I asked her why did you teach me to
speak instead of teaching me sign
language and I said Caroline it because
I wanted you to connect with anyone in
this world I wanted you to introduce
yourself and say hello I want you to
stand in front of an audience and
express yourself and your ideas not a
day goes by I'm not grateful for her
teaching how to speak the ability to
connect with anyone is such a privilege
I'm able to connect with anyone I can
and through the positive learning how to
speak I going to learn about the power
of the word I'm gonna share a few short
story with you about the power of the
word and then about six minutes later
here's how she ended her low-key note
you measure life to words words are like
seeds when you say them and so they're
thinking about being a seed or they can
ground something beautiful words can
distance or they can conduct words can
harm or they can heal and words can
transform lives that they have done for
me all of you as you go through this
life think about how we use the power of
the word to connect inspire and to lift
up thank you I'd like to let that play
that you begin to see the standing
ovation that her peers gave her at the
end of that talk in a minute I know some
of you are taking photos of slides I'll
give you a URL that you can go to the
playlist also so we've got almost we've
got nearly 200 talks up online from this
program and we do the talks in person
here on campus of the first week of
March March 2nd through 6 so if you're
in the area be in touch with us we would
love to have you see some of the talks
in person the
next step directly related to this is
leveraging YouTube now there are many
social media platforms but I want to
talk about the way YouTube has made our
leaders communicate more effectively
one is through low key notes like the
students have the stakes are high
because they know this could be seen by
an is seen by the world so we've got the
low key note talks that are up there we
started low key notes in 2012 and as of
last night we have three million four
hundred and twenty-two thousand views of
these students talks from a nine minute
talk in a classroom at the GSB the the
lives that they're touching the impact
that they're making the difference that
they're having because of what we can do
with social media technology is amazing
in addition to the individual talks I
also have a program inside of my
strategic communication class where the
students do a final presentation at the
end of class they do a team presentation
and it's on a communication topic of
their choice and and if the talks are
good enough and all four students sign a
release form we also put those talks up
and we've got 5.3 million views together
between these two programs we have
almost 9 million views of student work
here at the GSB and that second library
of communication talks has great things
in there like how to deal with anxiety
how to use body language effectively how
to design PowerPoint slides how to have
difficult conversations and so the the
the power of what YouTube can do for our
students is pretty remarkable and so I'm
gonna give one last video clip and just
give you a sense of the talks that are
up there now this talk in particular if
we're at here make body language your
superpower I'm going to come out of full
screen for a moment here just to give
you a sense of a wanted to be able to
see the to see the the number of views
this talk is the
single-largest viewed in the library and
it is almost three million views of
people who've watched this talk
they keep tracked when Oprah did the
view from the top speech here her talk
doesn't have as many views as their talk
does and they keep recording that so I'm
just going to show you the final speaker
in that team presentation but what
happens when the audience doesn't
realize they are on this okay whether
we're playing on our phones falling
asleep looking at the clock and
calculating can we make an escape from
this room we've all done it but the
thing is it's the speaker's
responsibility to understand what's
going on with their audience and body
language is a powerful way to assess
that as a speaker we can be so focused
on our own body language that we never
even notice what the audience is doing
and it's important to change that so I
want to share three strategies for how
you can engage with your audience better
by developing more observational skills
so first of all absolutely be using the
gestures and body language tools that
we've talked about today and over the
course of the quarter but the second
thing is to notice of course you're
going to be looking for
contact it look beyond it look at how
your buck how your audience members are
sitting
are they fidgeting are they moving are
they leaning forward looking engaged and
taking notes or are they something out
if your body language your eye contact
and your efforts of being compelling or
not working then you can go deeper you
can try to surprise the audience with a
question or use some humor or you can
disrupt the audience as students we hate
being cold called
effective right Jason what's your
favorite color as we all know it's the
fastest way to re-engage with the
conversation with the speaker so don't
be afraid to use it
it's so important to keep your audience
on track because they're the hero and
it's their journey remember how Nancy
Duarte had told us that we are the Yoda
to the Luke Skywalker and our job as the
speaker is to keep the hero on their
journey I think we've talked about three
concepts that really remind each of us
about how body language is your
superpower use it become that superpower
so I'm not superhero and we welcome any
questions you have on how to stand
strong gesture effectively and pay
attention to body language from the
audience I clipped it just a moment too
soon
and the the fact that I have these out
there I now assign them to students in
class that they watch them ahead of time
they know what the bar is in terms of
having one of their talks included in
the YouTube library and they are
learning about the communication that
they're teaching while they're teaching
in a way that I've had companies use
these in training I have high school
teachers reach out to me and say what
else is in the library I use this one I
want to have other talks that are there
so it really has become an element of
our success and the seventh piece to our
success is nurturing thought leaders now
I got to admit stefania's a little bit
subversive I still list in my bio that I
teach thought leadership at the GSB
even though the class was canceled two
years ago not because the students
didn't want it but the administration
wasn't sure that 20-somethings which is
primarily our student body could be
thought leaders it felt a little too
aspirational but I teach thought
leadership even though the class isn't
offered anymore in the work that I do
with students I'm just gonna give you
three quick examples of students in our
2020 class Michael Saltzman thought
leader in fraud in insurance and has
written is doing a start-up has written
articles have been featured in in
magazines because of the stand that he
has taken in this Mike Lewis wrote a
book before he was at the GSB when to
jump if the job you have isn't the life
you want and while he's been here at the
GSB he's been doing guest speaking on
campus and Beyond campus about the whole
concept of going from one career field
to a completely different career field
and then just Friday one of my students
the first talk that they do in class
it's a two to three-minute talk about a
leadership challenge one student Tammy
Chen posted her assignment on her own
LinkedIn page and has 11,000 views a
hundred and five comments and a job
offer because of her putting herself out
there as a thought leader about what
worked and didn't work in terms of
advice she got from a CEO the CEO she
quoted is the one who did make a job
offer to her and it was good advice that
she received but being able to work with
our current GSB students in the MSX and
the MBA program and occasionally the PhD
program when I get to these are
remarkable young adults who are thought
leaders in their own right and we find
ways that we can capitalize on that so
those are the seven secrets for
Stanford's success since oh seven it is
not the work that I have done I've been
a catalyst for it I stepped into an
opportunity at the right time with the
right leadership of the school looking
at wanting to build our skills skills in
writing and in public speaking and it
has just evolved it has just taken off
and you really need to not be
Ellis of what the students are getting
today but proud of what your institution
is able to provide for each and every
student in the program so I promise you
there would be some homework for things
that you can do in order to approach
mastery now keep in mind you're never
going to get to perfection but to
approach mastery first watch some of the
GSP videos on YouTube I'll give you the
URLs in just a moment great thing to
bring into your organization's great
thing to share backstage one of the
other Award winners was telling me that
that before she even knew what low key
notes was somebody had forward her one
of the low key note talks and that's how
she learned of the program existing here
it's inspiring it's motivating it's
educational to embrace aim in everything
that you're gonna communicate anytime
you're gonna write or speak to a group
of people professionally or personally
slow yourself down who's my audience
what's my intent if I can't answer those
two questions don't go on to message
until you get those and then create a
message that's going to inspire that
audience to take that action that you
want them to take third back at school
at least for a weekend commit yourself
to personal mastery what are the areas
in your writing or your speaking or your
use of social media or your
participation in meetings that you know
you could take some steps to improve
incremental steps working with a coach
having an editor going to a colleague
and making a commitment to coach each
other in how we're showing up in our in
our communication as leaders and fourth
be bold step into your own thought
leadership it has never been easier to
do a blog to do a TEDx talk to put
yourself out there into a specific
community as a thought leader on a
specific subject even if it's a subject
you have not yet mastered you know it's
something you need to work on choose a
smaller community and step into thought
leadership in that my husband and I
right now are co-teaching a class at his
ease and minister we're co-teaching a
class at his church on financial
management and budgeting for families we
don't do that real well
but we knew by teaching the class we
would have to get better at it it has
transformed our relationship to money
and our relationship to budgeting
because we said we will be the thought
leaders for this group of 20 people on
this particular topic and we're maybe a
chapter ahead of them but we're leading
them in in the thought process and
changing what what weird the legacy
we're gonna leave for our three kids
because we're gonna be better at it than
we were
so step into thought leadership so
finally I promise Oh perfect where I
wanted to be timewise I will have time
for a few questions in a moment here let
me talk about the the resources that are
out there to support you first of all
this is the slide to get your get your
camera's on if you want these are the
the URLs that will get you to the two
video libraries that I curate here at
the GSB and and I invite you to spend
some time looking at those two libraries
in addition to the videos that are out
there
since I'm speaking to some people of
generations that that know there are
these things called books they're
printed on paper and people open them
and read them and there are some books
that I just think are exceptional for
leadership communication manie's
Brousseau who wrote the textbook on
thought leadership ready to be a thought
leader she is a graduate of the GSB in
1993 and kotico taught the class with me
one of our communication coaches Chris
lip working with with students in
entrepreneurship developed a book on
pitching called the startup pitch and
then Matt Abraham's who spoke here last
year best title for a book speaking up
without freaking out fifty strategies
for being for overcoming anxiety three
great books that have come out of or a
part of the program we do here and then
the two leaders that I see in the field
right now Nancy Duarte who has several
books out there but I think her book
resonate is is the best we use that as
the text in our class and then the
credibility code by Carol alter great
small tax based on communication in
Silicon Valley so we've got a few
minutes for questions
before I close are there any questions I
can answer and if we can get the mic
runners out any questions up here in the
front in the blue plaid shirt and she's
right next to you with the mic like
maybe most of us maybe all of us here I
love Stanford and it's been a great
opportunity but you said something kind
of shocking a few moments ago which you
may or may not recall probably do which
was that they killed the course on
thought leadership and my thought is
that must have happened out of fear and
that's not my experience of the
leadership or the quality or the caliber
of the school so what the hell is going
on I was being a little provocative and
bringing that up and I was hoping John
Levin would still be here but I'm sure
you know I have a chat about what I
chose to share there is a challenge in
academia in terms of a limited number of
slots and a limited number of classrooms
that we can teach and decisions get made
about which classes to offer by a small
group of faculty who are looking at a
number of issues this was a course I
really hated to see us lose and even
though we lost the slot for the class
I've looked for other ways that I can
encourage thought leadership and keep
the torch alive that this may be
something we could reintroduce at some
point in the future
it was also co-taught with an alumna and
I think the more alumni and women that
we get in the classroom with us that the
stronger that experience is so I'm
hoping that it will still come back
another question on this side I'm all
that stands between them and more
alcohol right okay one more question
okay final question so I'm a dinosaur 30
years ago GSB and we didn't have this
amazing theme called PowerPoint then yes
so do you have any observations on
whether that the ways in which that
either enhances or can interfere with
effective communication because
certainly in my observation it can
become a crutch and so just interested
in your thoughts there yes it like any
tool it can be used effectively or
ineffectively many of us have
the experience of death by PowerPoint
where there's just too many words too
many things going on too many animations
and and it's again goes back to the aim
model who's your audience why are you
showing this and where where do you want
to take them Amanda Tucker and I had a
conversation earlier about her team at
Nike and that it's very easy to just put
a lot of data in front of people without
using it to tell a story and so looking
at how do I use PowerPoint effectively
to show you the thought process I endure
some stuff in PowerPoint that you know
in the 1980s was not even possible and I
can also kill a class with really bad
PowerPoint or kill a meeting with really
bad PowerPoint what I loved to do at
times when students are getting too much
into their PowerPoint I will just walk
up to the keyboard and hit the letter B
take it to black they don't know keep
going keep going you're fine you know or
if it's a smaller room I'll just close
their laptop say no go ahead I want to
hear what you have to say so that
they're in the conversation not in the
slides at an experience in here the
first time I did a talk in here four of
the low keynote students doing their
final low-key note talk and for some
reason on that day that projector and
that screen and that computer were not
talking and I had to go to two young men
who'd worked on their talk since January
and this is this is now May and I said I
don't know what we're doing I don't
think I can solve the slides can you
present without slides today they took
like a half second they looked at each
other
smiled look back at me and said you bet
we took the screen up and we had a great
conversation the two women who were on
that on that stage that day weren't
using powerpoints there was no impact to
them later we edited the slides in when
it went up on YouTube but it didn't hurt
their conversation because they knew
their material well enough so it's a
tool we just have to use carefully and
thoughtfully so this is the part of the
presentation where I show the resources
that other people have out there and
that I use in my classes I am thrilled
that for the first time I actually get
to list my own book up there
this summer I was able to take some time
before starting my new job at night
Hennessy and write a book called
communicate with mastery and I really am
able to look at what we have done over
the last 12 years at Stanford and
provide a resource to people who haven't
had the benefit of being in our classes
and I'm awed by Joel Peterson wrote the
forward to the book John Levin wrote one
of the testimonials on the back cover
and it really is allowing me to take
what I've been doing in class and get to
a wider audience
I will be out in January from Wiley but
I'm just delighted that I am able to
step into my own thought leadership for
something I've wanted to do for a very
long period of time and what I've shared
with you today is really kind of an
executive summary of what is there and
so with that the last slide that I will
offer is let's keep the conversation
going I have loved the chance to be here
and to be a part of Reunion Weekend
can't stay this evenings I've got to get
home and pick up children from daycare
and be dad tonight and your reunion
really needs to be about you and your
classmates and the memories that you
have but I am happy to share what is
going on in the classrooms here at GSB
in the low keynotes program in the GSB
communication lessons collection and who
knows what innovations we're going to
come up with in the next year with the
team of coaches and faculty that we have
committed to helping our students write
and speak more powerfully I began by
saying you cannot perfect communication
you can get better and better and better
you can get closer and closer to it but
you're always approaching mastery you're
never at perfection I'll close by saying
you cannot not communicate you can't you
cannot not communicate no matter what
you do what you say what you write
whether you reply to that email or you
don't whether you send that tweet or you
hold off on that text you cannot not
communicate everything we do as leaders
communicate something
to someone somehow so if you take on the
principles we've talked about this
afternoon you will be more likely to
have the message that's communicated be
exactly what you wanted because you
cannot not communicate so let's own what
we will communicate and tell some great
stories this weekend thank you
[Applause]
[Music]